[Applause]
how are you
bud how are you very good thank you very
much for coming on
well you know you're the cutest thing
[Applause]
you know you can put your shoes under my
bed anytime
[Laughter]
i'm not ready for you it's too late at
night yeah
how are you thanks so much for coming on
thank you for asking me
yeah we you know we were talking today
the the film looks hysterical by the way
the film looks very funny and everyone's
talking about it it was a big it was a
big hit over the weekend
no kidding yeah huge
i mean i got another job
that's right but how are you you do i
mean we were talking about today we were
just looking at all your credits all the
stuff you've been
so much theater but all these tv shows
so many people when they see you
recognize you from all these classic tv
shows 60s 70s 80s
and you're still going well you know i
just love show business yeah
i always want to be in show business so
i'm in showbiz of course i'm unemployed
but i'm in show business
what would you have done if you weren't
uh if you if you weren't an actor what
would you have done if you had done
something else what did you want to be
i've been a stripper
[Applause]
[Music]
this guy's gonna marry you now yeah
that's cool
that's cool yeah can i can i ask this
might be an indelicate question but uh
how old are you you look terrific oh
nothing no better than young enough to
try
all right what the that got to do
with hey
what was that
so how do you talk to your grandchildren
what kind of bedtime stories do you tell
them well they say grandma will you tell
us a bedtime story
i said why yes
so will you tell us the one about when
you was a hole in chicago
oh man
[Applause]
all right oh my god
whatever i'm afraid to ask you another
question
i've never been so scared in my life let
me ask you though i i will ask you this
you know the wayans brothers you're in
this in this movie with them
and in this movie you play a pot-smoking
grandmother
yeah now finally an issue all americans
can get behind yeah
how did you feel about that when they
came to you and said you're going to
play a pot smoke and granny
i love zaretha
[Applause]
you don't want nobody know it right
that's a good good read for you guys
it's in here yeah after the show that's
what this mug is for you
people always want to know what's with
the eisenhower mug oh my god
the police are going to raid this
interview anyway now
take us all away i don't know what else
to ask you
just i'm afraid i'm so afraid oh baby
don't be
scared
i won't let nobody hurt you you won't
let anybody hurt me all right no you're
the sweeter little thing
thank you just stay with me all right i
want you here all right okey-dokey
you know we are out of time i i i want
to can you come back because we gotta
talk some more this is
yeah i mean let me see let me see let me
see wait wait hey
wait a minute i was supposed to be in
l.a tomorrow
i have to ask my manager all right well
listen your hands are manageable
[Laughter]
[Applause]
will you come back yeah we gotta talk
we didn't get to anything it was just uh
come back soon would you please do that
thank you so much really nice to meet
you nice to meet you come back next time
we'll shut the place down for you okay
all right okay
helen martin everybody
the movies don't be a menace to south
central while drinking your juice in the
hood
we'll be right back after this